Hành trình mang tích ở phía với cầu bằng.
Trong 2,512,530 đoàn công tác của khu khuổi giò đồng chiến lâm vâm mấn,
chú tích hội đồng dân tộc giữ đầu đã có chuyến thâm để ý nghĩa tại tình cầu bằng.
Nghe 2,530 tham hoại vùng cân tự cách mạng giả trường hay đoàn đã đến tham,
đồng viên và trọng quả trở có ra định chính sách,
người có công và các em học sinh dân tộc thử số có hoàn cạnh khó khăn.
Tham, làm việc tại đồng viên phòng khuổi khổ sức sàng,
tại đây, đoàn đã cho 2 mi sức khoả trở các hộ gia đình chính sách,
gia đình thú bình, lửa xí, người có công với các mạng,
2 mi sức khoả trọng sinh dân tộc thử số từ việc có hoàn cạnh khó khăn,
trên địa bàn xá trường hà, cho khoả đồng viên cá nụ,
chiến xí đồng viên phòng khu khổ sức sàng.
Đoàn cho tặng một trong phần quả tế của bụ sinh tộc và tùng xáu trở các hộng
nhau có hoàn cạnh khó khăn, tặng qua đảng Ui, bị bán nhân dân,
bị bán mặt trận tộc khốt xá trường hà.
Sử dân tộc và tư dào tặng 2,
tặng 2 trong người có ủy tính trong đồng bảo dân tộc thử số trên địa bàn xá.
Sao mề hà mi tàng tháng 1, tế thêm đồng lục cho công nghiên,
người là độc đoàn phối hộ của bán công tác đại biểu vào linh đoàn
là độc tình tổ chức tặng một chân năm mì sức khoả tế
đã được chào tận tài những công nghiên khó hãn cạnh khó khăn,
giúp anh chỉ em đoàn sinh bình hộ hà như phù trang hà nơi sau thêm đồng ấm.
Chú tịch hội đồng sức tộc lông bán mất đả được giữ ngỗ lực lực là động bà như mạnh,
co bán phải đưa là đến tự vũ chắc, trong lo tốt nhất đời sống cho đàn biên.
Không đề hà bị bỏ lại phía sau, những phần qua thiết thực sự bà con và cố gên khá bằng đoàn sinh
lĩnh hộ hà như khu trang hà mi sau thêm ấm áp, trận bệng.